many enterprises today are getting
advantages out of moving workloads into
the public cloud
they're building cognitive applications
they're scaling them on demand
and they're improving the speed of their
development through as a service
api-based consumption on the public
cloud but the reality is
many workloads have not moved to the
public cloud yet many of those workloads
are from regulated industries
they have security and compliance
requirements or performance and latency
requirements
that make it challenging to physically
move those applications into a public
cloud data center
and what many organizations really want
is all of the agility benefits of public
cloud
but the flexibility to run those
workloads wherever they need them
on premise in their existing data
centers in multiple public cloud
providers around the world or at the
edge of the network
closer to the applications and data
sources that they need to process
public code is evolving to satisfy this
requirement with a new concept called
distributed cloud
so the heart of ibm cloud satellite is
the notion of ibm cloud services
managed anywhere when you consume
capabilities on the ibm cloud today you
have a catalog of over 130 services that
you can use
to build and run your applications
everything from infrastructure
to kubernetes and openshift databases
devops tools
and frameworks for ai machine learning
and iot
all of those services are available as
apis that you can provision on demand
and you can consume and use to build
your applications with ibm cloud
satellite we're extending that catalog
of services
and enabling it to be consumed in the
exact same way through the same apis
in locations outside of ibm cloud
regions
so you can now consume an openshift
cluster in your data center
or a ai machine learning framework in
your factory
you can use those capabilities in a
consistent way
wherever the application workload needs
to run you can also use
software things like ibm cloud packs and
open source capabilities and deploy them
in a consistent way
across any environment one of the
advantages
of this approach is that the public
cloud becomes kind of the central
management or control plane
for all of your distributed workloads
you have a single console that you can
log into
with ibm cloud that allows you to
provision resources
provision cloud services configure them
provision your applications and manage
them
in a consistent way across this diverse
set of environments
you get a single way to do security you
also get of course common observability
logging and monitoring and dashboards
and alerts that allow you to monitor the
workloads that you're running
in a consistent way across all these
environments we're also doing some work
in satellite to help you with
inventory and change management so part
of the power of satellite is this common
control plane or single pane of glass
that allows you to manage your
applications across a diverse set of
environments
now how does this work kind of the key
idea within satellite that we're
introducing is the notion of a location
a location is a way to define two ibm
cloud
a place outside of ibm cloud where you
want to be able to deploy
and consume cloud services it is a
collection of infrastructure that you
own
that we're going to use on your behalf
to run cloud services
that location is essentially a
collection of linux
hosts of virtual machines or physical
machines that get arranged together into
a pool of resources
that get managed automatically by
satellite and that get used
by us to provision services so when you
let's say want to create a satellite
location in your data center
you can provision a set of linux
machines within that data center
you register those linux machines with
ibm cloud
as a location and once that collection
is registered with ibm cloud satellite
you now see that location kind of as
like a custom region within your cloud
account
where you can now deploy cloud services
so if you want to create a postcards
database
define a devops tool chain or create an
openshift cluster
when you provision that cluster through
services in the cloud that custom
location you just defined in your data
center
will be a location that you can select
when you provision that resource
and so locations are is a really simple
concept where you're able to take
any linux infrastructure and make it
available
as a place to run cloud services now one
of the advantages of this idea of a
location
is it really provides a tremendous
flexibility ibm cloud satellite is built
on top of kubernetes and openshift as
the common infrastructure abstraction
that we use to allow you to consume
cloud services
in any infrastructure and by using
openshift as that abstraction layer
we can support a variety of
infrastructures underneath a satellite
location
you can bring your own custom
infrastructure in your data center
physical or virtual
servers you can use your account on
another public cloud like amazon or
azure or google
and consume that infrastructure and
arrange it into a location that's used
by ibm cloud for running cloud services
now since those locations those services
and applications are managed by ibm
cloud we of course need a connection
back to the cloud to help us manage
those things and that connection is
provided by a component called satellite
link and the idea of satellite link is
to give you the transparent visibility
to all the
data that's flowing back and forth
between the cloud and that location
and to give you control over what
applications and resources are exposed
in those locations
so these two ideas of location and link
provide the fundamental new concepts
that satellite introduces to ibm cloud
to give you the power of services
anywhere we're also going to provide
some optimized solutions
fully integrated rack systems both from
ibm and from partners
and as a service infrastructure
capabilities where we can run the entire
stack for you from hardware
through infrastructure and up into
platform and sas applications
and so you can consume infrastructure
either with what you have
you can build new environments or you
can run multi-cloud environments
across ibm cloud and other public cloud
providers so those are kind of the core
ideas in satellite
locations and link allow us to extend
our cloud catalog services to any
location
giving you the power of cloud and the
power of ibm cloud
anywhere in the world that you need it
all you need is some linux
infrastructure
and ibm does the rest thanks a lot
you